the unions have accused the health
secretary of being afraid to debate the
issues raised by the new contract they
accuse him of forcing this one down
their throats we go to Westminster in
the Health Secretary Jeremy Hunt is
there with us this morning good morning
to you secretary good morning Erin
not somebody could die today if so
you've got to take some of the
responsibility haven't you well the
people who are responsible for what has
happened today are the people who are
choosing to strike striking withdrawing
emergency care as you say for the first
time in NHS history is a choice and all
I would say is that we have had huge
discussions over how we deliver a
seven-day NHS we've been having them now
for over three years we've had 75
meetings but you can disagree with what
the government's trying to do we say
that you can't choose which day of the
week you're ill and that's why we want
to promise every NHS in fairness second
estate they're saying you're trying to
deliver a seven-day NHS with five day
resources yes well that's not true
because this year we're actually putting
into the NHS the sixth biggest increase
in funding in its history but what we
know is that if you're going to improve
the NHS it isn't just about money it's
also about making sure that care
actually gets better for patients and as
I say you can disagree with the
government's vision for a seven-day NHS
but is it proportionate or appropriate
to withdraw emergency care from
vulnerable patients because that's
what's happening today the single issue
that we couldn't agree on where the
deadlock was was over Saturday pay and
we are offering doctors higher premium
for Saturday pay their nurses and
paramedics than the assistants who work
in their own operating theatres this is
a very fair deal and the question on
many people's mind is given that given
that you know police officers and fire
officers don't get any premium at all
for working at the we keep talking about
money right how much money we're talking
about how much money you're going to see
if by not paying them
what they want on a Saturday for
instance well we are paying them more
what they're actually getting on a
Saturday depending on the time of day as
time in a third or time-and-a-half so
we're not saying if you work regularly
on Saturday that we're not going to pay
more but the reality is that we can only
pay them at levels that mean that we can
afford to have proper medical cover at
weekends you'll be saying all the ways
you could save money in the NHS of all
the the people you could club I mean if
you were going after the pharmaceutical
companies who were making massive
profits over over medicines and things
people may say well done people don't
want you to be clubbing doctors do they
well and we're not and you know as you
know perfectly well 75% of doctors will
actually see their pay go up under the
new contract and the doctors pay bill
will not be going down it'll be going up
but what we're saying is that you know
the first line on the first page of our
manifesto was a seven-day NHS in the
general election we had last year and
that is because you know if we are going
to offer high-quality care in the NHS we
want to be able to promise every patient
it doesn't matter which day of the week
you get ill you can't control that but
you can be confident of the same high
quality care from your NHS that's
something that's overwhelmingly
supported by the public but we have a
duty now to deliver that manifesto
promise and a no Union however powerful
however popular has a right to veto a
manifesto promise that the British
people are voted for so this is not
about money this is not about principle
this is not about medicine this is about
politics now this is about some
manifesto that you've had I mean this is
you against the union's then well I'm
sorry but you can't dismiss the
manifesto and say it's just about
politics a manifesto is what political
parties promised before elections and
what would you be saying to me in a
year's time or two years time if I was
on this program and I said I'm really
sorry I didn't deliver what we promised
in our manifesto because it was a little
bit difficult at the time and the
doctors union didn't like it you would
accept that wait so you made a promise
to the British people no we made this
promise for a tell seven day and age
and we have a duty if properly funded I
suppose but see how I said to you we're
putting okay huge amounts of extra
planning I mean there's 3.8 billion
pounds yes of extra funding going into
the NHS this year but I have met too
many patients who've told me
heartbreaking stories of tragedies that
they and their families have suffered
because they didn't get the care that
they needed at we say having more junior
doctors at the weekend would would stop
that but you have to have the ancillary
services as well exactly and that's what
I said in my statement yesterday that
this isn't just about junior doctors
it's about consultants is about
seven-day diagnostic services it's about
seven-day access to the social care
system it's about seven-day GP services
it's about a whole range of services to
make sure that NHS patients often we're
out of time they get we're heading
towards the break just some concern
about you are you running the show still
are you still in charge here the fact
that we're talking about politics are
you being told what to do by the prime
minister or is this your ballgame the
Prime Minister owner how are absolutely
at one that our solemn responsibility is
to deliver what we promise to the
British people we would do and that is a
seven-day NHS so they can be confident
in their NHS care every day of the week
health secretary thank you for your time
this morning we're not just over half an
hour away from this Oh like strike
appreciate your time thank you we have
to leave it there thank you very much
indeed as a Secretary of State for
Health Jeremy Hunt there's a Sky News
sunrise on a Tuesday back after this